what's up believe nation my name is that
when Carmichael my one word is believe
and I believe that entrepreneurs are
going to solve all of the world's major
problems I started to see to know series
try to learn a little bit more about
some of our famous entrepreneurs that we
love and look up to and try to give you
some new facts and little behind the
scenes things that maybe you didn't know
before until today we're going to learn
nine surprising facts about Warren
Buffett fact number one he bought his
first stock when he was 11 years old I
bought my first stock in the spring of
1942 I was 11 and if you remember you
don't remember no one was watching this
will remember but but we were losing the
war at that time and we were getting we
were we were getting totally creamed in
the South Pacific and the Philippines
fell in the death march of Bataan and
all that sort of thing not until the
Battle of Midway which was a little
later the things started turning around
what I was optimistic on the country
then and I've been optimistic on the
country ever since and incidentally the
Dow Jones average then was 117,000 knows
it's no one has ever been a success
betting against America since 1776 and
they're not going to be a success in the
future doing it either fact number two
he was rejected by Harvard University
and subsequently went to Columbia where
he mentored under Benjamin Graham so
when you graduated from university
braska you applied to Harvard Business
School and were rejected that's true
has Harvard ever announced that they've
regretted that this one I understand the
development officers kind of unhappy
so you rejected by Harvard you went to
Columbia Basel and then you met the man
who you really idolized men Graham and
when you took his class was he as great
as you had thought he was going to be he
really was the only he only taught one
semester one class and they came up from
Wall Street and taught this class that's
the reason I went to Columbia and he I
knew what he I do I don't really read
all the books and everything cited but
it was inspirational just to be around
him and I would made a real difference
in my life
fact number three he reads 5 to 6 hours
a day
I should mention one thing about reading
it was at the library here at combien I
wish I spent probably more time than
this any other soon I lived there
practically but and I pulled the book
out there happen to who's in American it
told me something about my professor
Benjamin Graham and then I looked up and
I went to the library and I said I want
to look more learn more about this
because I learned this over here that
changed my whole life
you know we owned I go down because of
that library and directing me to some
other book and then following through on
that night it's the chance I read about
150 pays the bill does I still spend
five or six hours a day reading I mean
it just you can learn so much I
particularly love biography just to be
able to live the lives of these people
live Ben's excited
and seeing so extraordinary the lessons
and those you know the discouragements
they say it's just everything about it
so I did you can't get enough of reading
fact number four he plays bridge 12
hours a week if I'm playing bridge and a
naked woman walks by I don't even see
her so trust me on that
yeah when he's not counting money he's
counting cards Buffett plays bridge
about 12 hours a week high one time said
that you know that I wouldn't mind going
to jail if I had the right three
cellmates so we can play bridge all the
time fact I might even prefer are there
lessons for business for later life in
this game well there's a lot of lessons
in it you
to look at all the facts you have to go
inferences from what you heard what
you've seen you have to discard improper
theories about what the hand has as more
evidence comes in sometimes you have to
work with your partner particularly on
defense not to say that bridge will ever
be as big as it once was but you can do
worse than heating advice from war and
Buffett I've never met anybody that
spent the time to learn the game that
didn't consider it one of the great
things in their life fact number five he
earned money by delivering newspapers as
a kid and he still loved doing it
Buffett says from delivering papers he
learned the importance of hard work and
reliability
I also learned frankly that that if you
did a good job
you were you were going to you were
going to move up I mean had the very
fact that I did a good job in Spring
Valley got me the Westchester routes
later on him getting the five building
Westchester complex home to Washington's
elite transformed a job into a business
by the time World War two ended Buffett
not yet fifteen had saved what an
average American earned in a year I was
fortunate in that I was here during
probably the most interesting periods
you could be in Washington during World
War Two I mean I I delivered the papers
when Roosevelt died when the comic bomb
was dropped
newspapers remain close to Buffett's
heart he owned several and a newspaper
tossing contest is a regular event at
his Berkshire Hathaway annual meetings
you know man
I still like to deliver papers if
anybody's got an open paper right out
there I'll be glad to help
back number six he drinks five Coca
Cola's every day they bring probably 5
12 ounce coke today and that's about 700
calories and I've been doing it more or
less all my life I can't imagine anybody
that feels better than I do I mean I'm
happy I enjoy life you know and I've
always wondered if I'd had a twin and he
had to eat broccoli and asparagus and
Brussels sprouts and done it every day
and I'd been drinking my cold and eating
potato chips and there are some cookies
that also you know have a hundred
calories per ounce the you know which of
us III think the other guy would be gone
I mean I think he probably would have
committed suicide thank you and he
certainly wouldn't feel as good about
life as I feel good every day fact
number seven he was awarded the
Presidential Medal of Freedom by Barack
Obama as a world renowned investor and
philanthropist Warren Buffett's business
acumen is matched only by dedication to
improving the lives of others
he is a co-founder of The Giving Pledge
an organization that encourages wealthy
Americans to donate at least 50% of
their wealth to philanthropic causes
Warren Buffett's example of generosity
and compassion has shown us the power of
one individuals determination and
inspired countless women and men to help
make our world a brighter place
[Applause]
fact number 8 if you invested $10,000
with Warren Buffett in 1956 it would be
worth 500 million dollars today
performed my first partnership in May of
1956 so this was the year-end balance
sheet which I typed myself back up quite
a few titles in it and these are my
partners I had at the time and this was
my father-in-law that was my roommate in
college that was his mother my aunt
Alice that's my sister Doris and that's
her husband Truman and it was the gang
yeah if they if they kept a $10,000
investment and then when I liquidated
the partnership reinvested at Berkshire
Hathaway they would now have about 500
million in fact number 9 he loves
playing the ukulele and this is Warren
Buffett singing Frank Sinatra's at my
way joined by I was a bit of murmuring
let's do it here there now the end is
near and so I face the final curtain my
friend I'll say it clear I'll state it
son
something around which I'm certain I've
lived a life of small traveled each and
every Highway and more much more than
this I did it mom and I feel as we go
now that was absolutely ha ha ha ha
talent
and so know it's my great pleasure and
honor and I'm more nervous now than I've
been stadium stages but because there
were muffin and I are going to perform
for you ain't go and then this has been
described as a once-in-a-lifetime
experience if you understand why one and
again once you get a taste of these
girls yelling grouping they for tricular
attention to the first line because it's
what is all about you've got to give hey
am I'm your forearm as this Oreos
[Music]
little town romance story
[Music]
the globey
[Music]
the two of us
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
we got each others arms you got to
[Music]
we have blue
sorry so thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed this fun
video I'd love to know what did you guys
think leave it down in the comments
below which fact was the newest one for
you or did you not know or do you want
to add a 10 11 12 to the list as well
share your thoughts in the comments
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon